with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller
[Music]
welcome to the Vaughn cast this is the
NFL draft Edition
um I have a very very exciting guest
he's going to be taken early in this
year's draft
um I'm also going to be asking you
questions about the off season I'm
answering some draft question for you
draft questions for you guys so drop
those in the chat let's get to my guess
man my guess was the Texas high school
player of the year out of Rockwall High
School everybody from the Korea before
um heading to Ohio State where he holds
the record for both single game
receptions and receiving yards he also
earned the Rose Bowl MVP honors in 2022
after a record-breaking 15 catches and
347 wait wait 15 catches I ain't reading
that right 15 catches 347 yards you
sound like a man step he is also one of
the top wide receiver prospects in this
year's draft he is that he is the
um
highest rated receiver in this year's
draft and without further Ado it's my
guy Jackson Smith najigbo what up my boy
what's going on man thanks for having me
on
man I appreciate you for coming on the
show fam and my daughter from the crib
man I wanted to uh give you a
opportunity to celebrate your shrimps
you are going to be the number one
receiver taking off the board this year
because
wow
because I mean look at the film look at
what I've done look at my production and
um
you know I just think I'm the best
receiver in this drive I think I've
proven that
and you know my skill set you know it's
it's one of one there's great great
receivers in this in this draft and I'm
honored to be standing next to those
guys and uh and I know they'll be great
players
um but yeah man I just think you know
I'm second to none in this draft in
whatever category you want to bring up
and that's my boy man if you could if
you could write your own scouting report
on yourself what would it look like
uh I would just say uh mentally tough
physical guy on the field Amanda man he
beats his man his own coverage he finds
his own very QB friendly and a reliable
Target so but definitely raw I still got
things to improve on uh most definitely
but I think you can see that I get I get
there in and I'm motivated to get there
so I'm excited about you know this next
Journey
my dog raw man basically saying can't
nobody holding can't nobody touch it
they don't say hey go over the top on
anybody he'll take the reverse he'll do
whatever you need him to do man my
daughter run like David yeah
this whole this whole draft process has
been crazy for you I know right before
the interview you're ripping and running
um yeah but uh tell us tell us bro like
how's it been bro it's been fun it's
been stressful you've been enjoying it
man it's been a dream come true
um it's hard to complain man I can't
complain at all and you know it's a
blessing I'm running around and being
busy is a good thing you know what I'm
saying and it's an awesome opportunity
uh opportunity I've been looking forward
to for a very long time and you know to
be you know where you at Von you know
I've been you know chasing you and the
great the greatness you know that that
came out of Texas and now in the league
so you know if I can keep trying to go
down that path and and stay motivated
you know I feel like you know with hard
work I can do I can do just that and you
know I'm working to do that and I'm in
the right spot right now so just trying
to keep my head on straight and and get
ready for the drive
man you're gonna be good man I remember
when I was going through this process it
was interviews it was workouts that I
had to do it was also a lockout too so
we didn't have any OTAs or anything like
that so I also had some free time too it
felt like I was already in the lead but
I wasn't in the league but I was
training to get ready in the league and
I was doing interviews and stuff it was
dope man I really enjoyed it man I
remember it was so much anticipation on
who was going to get picked and who was
going to go number two or three because
I was supposed to go number three to
Buffalo Marcel yeah this is supposed to
go number two to the Denver Broncos but
it wasn't up until the draft when my
agent was like Hey Denver is going to
take you and buffalo is going to get
Marcel Darius I'm like bro that was
crazy bro and right when they picked me
number two bro I just had like a
flashback of like Little League
practices
um high school games all of my coaches
all of my my parents and my family
members that poured into me to get me to
that point man I just and I just bust
down crying fam like all right I don't
really cry that much man but when it
comes to your craft and you can really
put into perspective all the hard work
and really all the lucky breaks you get
because it's um it takes a little bit of
look it takes it takes those blessings
to be able to get you over the hump and
then at the same time you got to work
hard and you got to make this
happen fam so I already know how crazy
it is man you you got any um you you uh
have you been speaking to any teams I
know you worked out for the Dallas
Cowboys you know we we both from the
crib we we Dallas Cowboys fans already
know
yeah I've been talking to a few teams um
you know cowboys of course went home
um just got back from Baltimore and
Minnesota you know the list is long you
know visit with a lot of teams so and
like you said man you don't know until
your name is called anything can happen
and uh so we'll just have to wait and
find out but you know excited to to be
here for sure but playing for the Dallas
Cowboys would be cool with Dak Prescott
CD lamb Brandon Cooks Gallery I know hey
I know you got you got jse in there too
that'd be dope yeah definitely be dope
but Jason anywhere you know would be
dope and I'm just you know happy what
whatever team picks me up you know it's
just a blessing opportunity for me to
Showcase my time for that team and you
know try to get to that one common goal
you know
yeah we talk about
um you know you playing for the Dallas
Cowboys and matching you up with CD lamb
and there's a lot of guys that try to
say that your game is similar to CD lamb
how both of you guys are electric and
you both of you guys uh potential is
through the roof man
um is there is there any current NFL
receivers that you that have had a big
influence on your game I know you're
pretty cool with Gary Wilson as well are
there any receivers that you look up to
100 100 you know I'm a student of the
game I love the game I love receiver
work you know I just think it's an art
you know just matching up with that DB
and you know being in the room with Gary
Wilson and Chris olave guys I definitely
look up to and see them doing their
thing is definitely inspiring but you
know definitely I watch the best you
know I I watch Devante Adams and his
feet his his release work you know and a
lot of things he'd do Cooper cup his
spatial awareness you know taking
advantage of the DB Jamar Chase his just
play making ability
and you know Stefan Diggs you know the
the list is long you know I'm a student
of the game I love the game you know and
uh I try to look at myself as one one of
one though you know I kind of bring
something else to my game a different
chip to my game so but I definitely love
what the league is is doing and the
receivers in the league right now so you
know I'm just working to be you know up
there with those guys and hopefully I
can do that
man your former uh your former teammate
Gary Wilson it's crazy that y'all was
both on the same team how do y'all not
well yeah I was on the same team
together bro that's crazy bro but just
Gary Wilson is so good man I played him
uh during the season when he's with the
Jets man I just remember being on the
sideline like bro this this dude got it
bro he he fears
and this guy said Jackson I mean Garrett
Wilson said Jackson is cold-blooded we
call him the natural I'm confident that
wherever he goes he's going to be a big
he's going to make a big impact early
how did it make you feel bro coming from
Garrett Wilson the offensive Rookie of
the Year
man you know Garrett's my boy and we've
had a lot of talks and I appreciate
those words and I appreciate him just
sending the standard sand the bar for me
to reach
um and the ones that came before him
Chris olave those guys just you know you
know it's definitely hard you know it's
not an easy road to follow those guys
though they're having great careers and
they're doing their thing but I
appreciate it I look I look at it as
almost a challenge almost to to be up
with those guys and be well respected
and get the respect you know that those
guys got in the league so um I just
appreciate him I'm saying those things
it means a lot and you know we've had a
lot of talks and this is just the
beginning I'm just ready excited to put
the work in and you know get to that
level
man oh you know I went to Texas A M but
I'm a huge yeah I know of Ohio State man
oh man Ohio State they put him out I
actually was in Columbus I think I was
in Columbus two years ago I had went to
Canton right and I had missed my uh
flight back from the Hall of Fame back
to Denver so I had to drive to Columbus
for a night and I just remember being
there and like everybody was Ohio stayed
out everybody had a Buckeyes this Buck I
was at I was like bro I was like bro
this place is this place is dope man and
early oh man earlier unique about it's
crazy I know it's crazy man in about two
months ago we was at the Super Bowl we
had talked to CJ shroud man I love CJ
shrub
um it's a possibility of him going to
the Texans at two and you to the Texans
at 12. how cool would that be man to
play with CJ shroud in college and in
the league
man it would be awesome you know
um stress would definitely leave my body
just playing next and beside him you
know he's a good friend of mine you know
know what he likes and those dislikes
and you know he's not the same you know
and it'd just be awesome to have that
opportunity to be on the same team and
you know still have that connection keep
that connection going would be an
awesome opportunity
he's a crazy talented player and you
know wherever he goes you know he's
going to ball out so you know maybe
Houston I told that would be cool
man you boys in H-Town that'd be crazy
man they got the young bloods in there
running the city that'd be crazy come on
man what makes it what makes uh what
makes CJ special man
just his awareness is his god-given
abilities and you know every time he
steps on the field he's just he's the
smartest you know guy on the field and
you know he knows how to make the
defense pay just really smart you know
just you know before snap pre-snap
post-snap
um you know and he just makes it easy on
a lot of guys he's a great leader you
know no knows how to lead his team you
know you know people are going to follow
good people and you know that's what he
is he's a he's a great guy you know who
loves ball and it's hard not to follow
him you know when he speaks you know
everybody listens and you know he's
putting the work and you know I'm just
super proud of that guy for real
hey um
you know they had Joe Barrow and Jamar
Chase in Cincinnati and you see their
connection you and CJ shroud and with
the with the Houston Texans and the AFC
South versus the the Colts the Titans
and the um Jacksonville Jaguars where
y'all to tear that division up y'all had
the same type of Duo that burro and
Chase has this is something that's
something to think about man you never
know where to draft man it ain't like
you get to pick but if it ended up like
that man that'll be super dope man you
Ohio State guy
we got all these receivers coming out of
these big Tom schools you know some
people say that LSU is is wide receiver
you some people say Alabama is is wide
receiver you and a lot of guys say Ohio
state is wide receiver you
who is the real
wide receiver you
man
a m nah I'm playing with you you know
I'm playing hey we got some guys code
out of there one boy Texas a now nah no
no this to them you know they have a
great program but I think it's Ohio
State man hands down just yeah
seeing how we work
I mean rightfully so you know you know
Bama has a right to say that LSU has a
right to say that you know great great
receivers but who I was around in my
receiving room Jameson Williams Crystal
Ave Garrett Wilson Julian Fleming Marvin
Harrison Jr
oh man no Chris Carter
Gonzalez
Michael Thomas Terry McLaurin I can go
man the list is long you know I I got I
got my guys over anyone man I'll take
you guys too man but it's it's hard you
know because LSU has Justin Jefferson
obj Jamar chase you know Alabama has
Julio Jones Amari Cooper yeah and
Devonta Smith Jalen Waters I'm gonna
have to go with Ohio State too out of
all those receivers that went to Ohio
State who is the best route Runner
the best route Runner Marvin Harrison Jr
Marvin Harrison
who has the best hands
best hands Gary Wilson
who is the fastest
fastest Chris olave
Chris alive
those guys best footwork
best footwork
Marvin Harrison
Junior who is the who is the biggest X
Factor
biggest X Factor
man
that's hard Crystal Ave man
when he I would say
I would say Chris or Garrett oh
that's so tough expert man I gotta go
away you've been in the locker room with
these guys man who who has the best
locker room presence who's the coolest
off the field in the locker room man
they all got a different swag
um they all got a different swag and
they're all great dudes
um but Garrett Wilson his presence in
the locker room is a match you know just
a high energy guy loves ball all those
guys loves Ball but you know it's it's
cool I think Gary Wilson has that
presence in the locker room
it's dope man we had to you know we had
to uh you know give our Ohio State
receivers some love man
um you coming back from injury I'm
coming back from injury too
um you know I had told my uh my ACL this
last past season coming back year 12 two
years ago I dislocated my peroneal
tendon
um you've had to deal with some injury
as well you played three games this year
um you know missed a lot of time
um two years ago before then and
sophomore season you went crazy been
battling injuries all over the place um
what's your mindset what's your mindset
going into the league how do you deal
with all the adversity that that has
presented itself
man I'm hungry I am I am hungry
um I'm ready to get to the league and
and show him I mean I had dreams I had
goals for this season and for it to be
wiped away it definitely hurt me
um but I'm happy because you know
looking forward you know I'm more hungry
than ever have that chip on my shoulder
ready to get here get in here you know
I'm not satisfied with anything don't
feel like I've done anything and uh I'm
just excited that you know I have
another opportunity at the highest stage
and I'm looking forward to that
how did how did going through that
adversity
um how did you grow from you know
experiencing that adversity
man I mean mentally just just knowing
that you know you have a good foundation
I think number one just knowing you have
people you know that love you and you
know that care for you and that are
there you know for me to be able to you
know have my brother there have my mom
and dad and you know my teammates you
know it was you know that definitely
helped a lot and one just you know
knowing that it'll be better days you
know everyone goes through ups and downs
as football you know things are going to
happen and uh it's just try to control
what you can control you know I tried
you know to come back every single day
try to get back on that field and
compete for a national championship but
you know that's not what was written for
me you know I wasn't able to do that so
I'll just take you know what I got and
and put that energy to you know the next
thing
how tough how tough was it you know not
to play in the college football playoff
versus Georgia I know you want to be out
there with your guys man like yeah how
tough was it to to sit that one out
man tough I mean toughest thing I had to
go through as a as a player you know you
know your team you know needs you wants
you to be out there you know you know I
want to be out there more than just as
much as you know those guys and
um you're not being able to you know
help them it definitely hurts and on the
sidelines I never did that you know I've
been a healthy kid you know thanks to
God
um you know been a healthy kid never had
to miss games never had to miss practice
so me sending out you know it was tough
you know because I'm a player I love
ball I love competing at the highest
stage in front in front of you know the
fans and and you know everybody in the
world so that's who I am and for that to
be stripped you know it hurt you know
but you know it's past me I'm just happy
about the future and what the future
holds and you know just trying to
control what I can control by you know
just putting in work every day and
getting better
man you have a great mindset man it's
super dope it's super dope to talk to
you man
um like we said before you your dad
played linebacker at SFA your brother
plays for the pick the Pittsburgh
Pirates you got a team full of athletes
your grandparents your grandparents came
to the U.S from Sierra Leone in the
early 1970s
who was the biggest influence on the
person and player that you are today
I would say you know my father his hard
work you know not giving anything how to
earn it and you know seeing him you know
do his thing and make a lot of
sacrifices my parents made a lot of
sacrifice a lot of sacrifices for us to
you know do what we want to do and you
know play you know since a young kid
played the game that we love so you know
I appreciate them and I see all the hard
work and for me to take that hard work
you know that they have you know with
real life responsibilities and put it
into a game that I love man this is easy
I'm blessed man so I'm just thankful for
the opportunity
man you you a great dude man this is uh
it's been dope to talk to you man I see
you know a lot of myself and you man I'm
a Family Guy my brother is my best
friend my dad has always been in my life
with all the major decisions that I had
and just just looking at you and you
know seeing um you know all the uh
excitement that's coming up man I just
remember how excited I was on draft
night man
um being in New York being around my
peers man uh getting drafted picking out
my suit putting on the watch and the ice
and stuff do you got you got a soup you
got a suit picked up
man I got a couple I got a couple that's
going to take a game time decision man
my head's everywhere right now
man uh man you could you could rest
assured man that you can put all the
work in man and you know it's uh it's an
honor and a privilege to talk to you man
I appreciate you for doing my show man
if there's anything that you ever need
for me you from the crib bro you know I
got you bro I hit you on Instagram to
make sure you got my info man
um continue success I know um what
you've done in college just it's just a
little piece of what guys are going to
see in the league man and hopefully
it'll come to the bill so we don't have
to play you but I know the bills got the
Bills pick is way too late man it's way
you never know you never know anything
you never know I appreciate it I
appreciate you 100 you know just being a
Texas kid and watching you know a Texas
Legend before me and you know growing up
and going to the a m games and seeing
you it's a privilege and
um you know I'm trying to get to where
you are and I appreciate you for
inspiring and having me on the show the
show you're gonna get there man if you
ever need me bro you know I got you man
thank you
appreciate it good luck my G thank you
man absolutely
foreign
[Music]